[Music]
Gaps
[Applause]
And you can't go wrong with this scent
Who's gonna replace him with the fragrant hot water?
It's time to eat, oh riyo,
everyone
Spice Spice It's stimulating, but it's gentle and mellow.
It's a special curry made with seeds and garlic and ginger, and that's what Tsuno Otsuki is.
This is the snow and the demolition and the egg
Self-excited calendar Wh me
ah ah ah
[music]
There's no way you can do that kind of work just because you're so small You're sure
to rejoice right away Welcome to black
Meatball recipes and ingredients are quite arranged  It is
eaten in Taiwan and some parts of China, but it looks a lot
like hot pot lions.
I don't think I bought it with this, Yuuki!